hello everyone thank you so much for
coming
and thank you so much to Alex and Nick
let me introduce uh Nick first so Nick
is a senior sde at Amazon right uh Nick
is a applied scientist senior applied
scientist
you're a senior play Scientist and you
are senior SD okay and they are here
today to tell us about how to glue on
which is an open source ml framework
that can train all multimodal data like
table images is that correct yeah text
text images and tables yeah yeah all at
once all at once
so thank you so much for for to the
presenter for letting us know about your
work and for the people coming that are
interested in this talk and we will have
questions at the year we'll have 15
minutes for questions I will let you
guys know when those 50 minutes come
I'll be sitting here and thank you so
much oh okay
thank you so much let's start
all right let's do it
all right so hello everyone super happy
to be here today
um so I'm Nick Erickson I'm here with my
good friend and co-worker Alex sherkov
uh and we develop Auto gluon
so and we're today we're going to talk
to you about how you can leverage Auto
Glon to solve complex problems in
machine learning with potentially
multimodal data all at once in just one
line of code
and get a state-of-the-art solution too
so let's get started so yeah we have a
brief kind of template for how this is
going to go it's probably not actually
going to go like that we'll see
um yeah we do have some Hands-On
notebooks again I mentioned I don't know
if we're going to have a dedicated time
for that section since it's a fairly
short talk but we'll see
um
I I'd say let's let's just dive into it
so
um ml in a nutshell uh so with machine
learning I like to think of it in very
simple terms you bring your data you
train models you make predictions this
is generally the flow of most machine
learning right and so the question is
how can we simplify this process as much
as possible
so I think
um when we cut come to the topic of
Automated machine learning
um we need to think about what it means
to revolutionize the way in which people
use machine learning in practice how do
we make it simpler how do we make it
better and so I think that there's seven
steps needed to really have the
community Embrace Automated machine
learning
the first is that it has to be easy to
use and widely accessible for example
just by a simple pip install you have it
running or it runs on collab or even
without python at all such as on your
browser
it needs to have strong performance you
need to not be able to be sacrificing
your potential by using the tool right
it's not like oh it's easy but I get
worse accuracy No it should be it's easy
and you get better accuracy than if you
had used something else right it's
something that should Empower you
should have fast inference speed it
shouldn't be a tool that you use and
then you have to drop when you have to
productionize it because it's too slow
right this thing needs to be fast in all
dimensions
it needs to be stable and reliable it
needs to be able to scale up to large
production workloads it needs to be able
to not fail in edge cases right it needs
to be robust
it needs to be customizable if you have
a custom scenario such as you need a
custom evaluation metric you have a
model that works really well for your
data set and you want to incorporate it
in it should be able to support all of
those things
it should be interpretable in the sense
that you should be able to have ways in
which to understand how your data is
being leveraged by the system and also
what you can do to improve the result of
the system by basically adjusting your
data
and finally it should be Deployable the
final solution should be something that
you can just take directly to a
production system load it in and run and
basically start doing inference or
whatever you need to do so it should be
very portable it should be able to be in
just a couple lines of code shifted
across operating systems across cloud
services all that stuff right
and so I think that auto Glon as of this
year basically has achieved all seven of
these goals and this is what I'm going
to talk to you about today
so Auto gluon is an automl tool kit that
democratizes machine learning it
automatically builds powerful machine
learning models for image text time
series and tabular data with just a
single line of code
and it is open source and easy to
install this install it'll go on we're
also available on conda uh kind of
install auto Glen yeah
okay
so to give a brief overview Auto Glon
was used to teach over 15 000 Amazon
software development Engineers machine
learning in 2022 by a machine our
internal mlu or machine Learning
University day one ml course
it was also used in over 200 Amazon
production projects
and as well as the back end of major AWS
services such as uh sagemaker autopilot
which is Amazon's official automl
offering basically
it's also adopted by over 50 external
companies
including Intel Nvidia IBM Capcom
Mitsubishi all around the world
and it was used in the opening keynote
of the Auto Mall conference 2022 which
was the first ever automl conference
all right
let's get going
next slide
all right yeah and so overview again we
are fully open source no strings
attached we're on GitHub you can pivot
stop for free use it for free right see
those source code come join us and
contribute if you want right it's
available to everybody
um
so also we're available on Windows Mac
Linux we support on everything CPU GPU
python 3.8 the 3.10 soon to be 3.11
right
all right so let's talk about Auto glue
on its relation to automo so in Prior
work so basically you know thinking like
2020 and stuff like that Automall was
generally thought of as model plus hyper
parameter selection or the cash problem
so basically given that you have
um a a model that you want to optimize
right to get a better score you have
hyper parameters for that model you want
to kind of tweak the levers of the hyper
parameters to find something that
performs better than the defaults right
and that was kind of the goal of automl
was figure out what's like the best way
to tweak the levers and what should
those levers be set as right
um however ottugman is actually very
different from most automl systems and
that it instead relies on strategies
that wind protection contests and sites
like kaggle such as
um through thoughtful data preprocessing
model and sobling by a multi-layer
stacking which is a popular technique on
Kale which I'll get into a greater
emphasis on Modern deep learning
techniques as well as boatloads of
tricks and optimizations that we've
basically crammed in there over the
years
so let's talk a little bit about this so
hyper parameter tuning right this is
like the traditional approach to automl
so basically you know you have hyper
parameters to a model right and again
you're trying to tweak the levers to
find something that works better however
there is a price that you pay for doing
this
uh and so the Dropbox is for example it
requires that you train the model many
times right every time you want to
evaluate a certain uh configuration you
need to train the model again
and most of the models being trained are
thrown away and don't contribute to the
final result because how do you search
well a lot of times it's something like
random search you can do something
smarter like Bayesian optimization but
it's really not that much smarter than
random search
um and the more hyper parameter tuning
you do the more you're over fit on your
validation data which is a very severe
problem that's kind of underappreciated
in most literature
um and finally it's less helpful when
you are trying to find the optimal
Ensemble rather than the optimal model
so
let's talk a little bit about ensembles
I'm assuming a lot of you are probably
somewhat familiar with maybe a random
Forest if you've dived into machine
learning a bit so Random Force very
famous model it's very simple actually
so a random Forest is just a bunch of
random position trees averaged together
a decision tree is just a bunch of
binary decisions of splits of your data
so for example is someone male or female
is are they aged less than 30 years old
or greater than or equal to 30 years old
right and it's just a bunch of splits on
your data that separate the target
variable in the most efficient way
possible basically
um and yeah
so let's kind of look at how these
algorithms work so in this data we have
X we we are trying to predict the color
of the dot we have two variables X and Y
coordinates right so given the
coordinates predict the color of the dot
higher the the lighter the color the
higher the value it's called a
regression problem
so here's what a decision tree would
look like it would start making these
these these splits on the data right and
if we color it in we'll see that this is
what the decision tree would predict at
any given point in this in this space
right
now here is a bunch of different
decision trees
um each of them are obviously
sub-optimal right
um you know it's it's clear that there
is this
um this Improvement you could make
because there is these harsh decision
bounds where the color instantly changes
from one point to the next right
um but the magic is when you average
them together now you have a random
Forest
and the interesting thing about a random
Forest if we go to the next slide
is that a random Forest is stronger than
the strongest decision tree as in by
simply averaging a bunch of poor or like
sub-optimal decision trees together
you get something that is better than if
you hyper parameter to do a decision
tree forever
so in this sense ensembling was a
fundamentally more powerful technique
than hyper parameter tuning
so how can we leverage this in a more
General sense we'll get into that but
basically the takeaways of ensembling is
that many models are generally better
than few
and models that learn differently could
boost accuracy even though if they're
worse in isolation and Hyper parameter
tuning to find the best single model
does not necessarily help you find the
best combination of models
so let's talk about what people do in
practice to push machine learning to its
limits let's talk about ml competitions
so who here has heard of the Netflix
prize competition
okay a few people so the Netflix prize
is a pretty Infamous competition uh it
was a pretty old one I think in like
2009 or something like that yeah and uh
it was for a million dollars it was like
the highest paying ml competition ever
at that point I believe and the goal was
to beat Netflix's algorithm by 10 if you
beat it by 10 you win and you get the
million dollars
this took years
for someone to be able to do it was
extremely hard and in order to cross the
finish line the final result was so
complicated that Netflix didn't even
implement it
right and I will call this a monster
right what they did is they took
hundreds and hundreds of machine
learning models and combine them in very
complicated ways with all this custom
feature engineering right and
this is the most powerful thing that
anyone could have done at that time
right it's not like people were holding
back who was gonna hold back for a
million dollars right
so this is like the drag racing like the
absolute limit right
and
but again it's a monster it was so crazy
that you can't be productionized it was
too complicated
so but this isn't an isolated case this
is just one competition let's go to
Kegel
so or actually sorry I skipped a slide
so let's talk about
um
the origins of autoglan so here is
myself and my good friend Alex surekov
in 20 in 2018.
um we participated in internal machine
learning competition at Amazon called
the Scott Grand Challenge 2018 which was
to predict if two products are the same
or not basically the product duplication
problem at amazon.com which is a pretty
big deal actually when you have billions
and billions of products
um and so we ended up winning this
competition
um which is kind of in a lot of ways how
we ended up talking to you here today
um but that's another story so uh but if
we go back for just a moment right so
winning this competition was not a
trivial thing there was about 500 teens
in this competition right including like
scientists and stuff I was just an
engineer same with Alex Ray it's not
like we had phds or anything but we were
unreasonable just like how the Netflix
prize people were unreasonable we made
something that was absolutely ridiculous
right and it was more powerful than
anything else that anyone else did
basically
um but I realized I never want to do
this again after winning that
competition it was I never want to go
through the process of what I did again
um even though it was the best thing to
do technically it was super complicated
and super manual
right and this isn't an isolated case if
you go to Kegel right this is extremely
common all of these slides are rank one
prize-winning Competition winner or like
competition winning solutions to a
hundred thousand dollar plus
competitions all of these are very
complicated multi-layer stack ensembles
of hundreds of models feeding the
patients into other hundreds of models
all this crazy stuff
this is the kind of stuff they don't
teach in college courses by the way uh
or in papers by the way the saying in
papers
um okay so let's go on to the next slide
then
so my question that I posed
is can we tame the monsters right all of
these things I would consider monsters
and that they're the strongest things
you could possibly do realistically but
they're also almost impossible to use in
production right how can we harness that
power in production how can we tame the
monsters
so I think that we can ask some
questions right can we make them
reliably performance stable and sensible
to countless different data sets
assemble them in an appropriate manner
without need for expert Knowledge from
the user train them in a reasonable
amount of time on a wide variety of
Hardware they have a flexibility to
satisfy user constraints and hide
complexity behind an elegant API you
might realize this is basically me
restating those seven big goals in a
sense right
Auto Glon strives to achieve these goals
Auto glance strides to tame the monsters
so to obtain the upcoming results that
I'm going to show you
Auto blonde did not hyper parameter tune
Auto go on used the same hyper
parameters for every data set and every
problem
in fact we use the near default hyper
parameters for all of our models
and we train using the same three lines
of code for every problem
from autoglan.tabular import tabular
predictor
predictor equals tablet predictor
specify the label column that you want
to predict
call Dot fit specify the training data
it could be the path to the training
data of CSV file or it could be the
pandas data frame
specify your presets if you want for
example best quality
and specify your time limit do you want
it in 10 minutes an hour going home for
the night eight hours right have a
weekend 72 hours right however long you
want Auto Glen does its magic you come
back after that amount of time it's
ready right it's just going to do its
stuff for all the time you give it
and then finally you call one second we
got one more line predictions equals
predictor.predict uh and then pass in
your test data it can also be a pandas
data frame right and then you get your
predictions there's your machine
Learning System there's your production
system right
cool
all right so how do we so then what
exactly is going on under the hood here
so we got a lot of models right
basically we take everything that the
open source Community has to offer and
slam it into our system in a way that's
synergistic so we take all the greatest
models here I'm kind of talking a little
bit about tabular but we also got you
know the other stuff here so we've got
XG boost cap boost light gvm super
awesome GBM models uh we also got all
the scikit learn models we got fast AI
neural network models pytorch stuff we
got and then you know like for text got
a hugging face and we had for images we
have the pi torch image library or Tim
uh then we do this thing called bagging
so if you're familiar with cross
validation it's a very similar concept
it's actually the same Concepts it's
just that instead of throwing away the
models and just calculating a
cross-validated score you actually keep
the models and then you use them to
Ensemble them together to create a
stronger solution
again
you can think of a random Forest it's
just a bag of decision trees well we're
just going to bag any type of model
um but not only that so if we go back
this is going to be complicated for me
to describe in the time that I have to
talk about it you can read our paper if
you want to know more but this right
hand side this validation data Note that
we have a prediction on the validation
or basically about the prediction on our
training data which you can think of the
trained out as this complete data it's
everything we have there is no such
thing as validation data I guess you
could say
um and we after this process have one
model having made a validation
prediction for every row of our data
which means that for every row of our
data we have an un oh we have a
non-overfit prediction of of that row uh
prediction probability and again this is
a complex topic but we're going to call
this out of full predictions and we're
going to use this in a very interesting
way
so the magic ingredient
multi-layer stack ensembling this is the
monster
this is the thing that people use to win
kago competitions it's the thing that's
not really in any papers or in courses
and stuff like that but this is the most
powerful thing that exists basically
okay so a stacker model uses predictions
of every base model as extra features so
let's go through it this is our input
data right here this is like you know
our training data for example right or
just any kind of data right then we pass
these inputs into each of our models
just like normal right in this scenario
right you train a random Forest you
train an XT boost whatever everything is
normal however each of these things is
actually a bag
each of these is the diagram that I had
in the last slide right and each of
these basically does out-of-fold
predictions so that for every row of our
data we have a validation prediction
probability then the magic happens we
concatenate the prediction probability
of this model with the features of the
data and do and add it as a new feature
to the data this is automated feature
engineering
uh via machine learning models basically
this feature is what would light GBM
have predicted given this information if
it saw this at test time you can think
of it as that kind of information right
what would random Forest have thought
what about a neural network what about
Bert what about uh what about resnet
right
um all of that that's the kind of
information we're passing along and this
is actually a very powerful feature
right
um You can shorthand a lot of learning
uh in your future models if you have
these kinds of features that can prove
things sufficiency a lot it also helps
you with Synergy right certain models
might work together well and if both of
them are confident that you can just
kind of say oh yeah no this is the
correct answer very confidently right
but if they disagree maybe that then
then you can leverage features in a way
where you know which models leverage
some features well or some others and
you can have a closer dive into them
right and so basically then you train
stacker models with these extra features
right and it's actually for our purposes
the exact same models of these same
hyper parameters as the first layer and
you can just keep doing this however
many layers you want I'm going to
simplify and just say we do two fully
connected layers here and by the way
when I say fully connected that might
spring a certain idea into your head you
see if we flip this 90 degrees what
you're actually looking at is a deep
neural network with a skip connection
um because it's actually the same thing
deep neural network is actually just a
specific implementation of a multi-layer
stack ensemble
we have just generalized this to the
general case of the stack Ensemble and
we can now do instead of a perceptron
with a neural network right as our
neuron we have light GBM we have xgboost
we have resnet
Etc right this allows us to do very
powerful things and get very powerful
results
okay
let's go on to the next slide
so how good is this so back in 2020 we
released our paper Auto go on tabular
and we compare it against the
state-of-the-art systems at the time
what we saw is that we beat the best in
hindsight combination of all existing
competitors
which means basically we take first
place in over half of the data sets
additionally we did 11 Kegel data sets
of which we placed within the top 30
percent of human competitors on average
and on two of the 11 competitions we
placed within the top one percent this
was with four hours of compute on eight
CPU cores in 2020.
um however now you might ask okay but
that was 2020 what about now right so
the most recent comprehensive study on
automl systems was in systems for animal
research by phibbers as well as an
automl Benchmark which is also by Peter
and I think some people from H2O
um so in this paper they evaluated all
of the most powerful Automotive Systems
and autobuan was the only system which
significantly outperformed the other
systems basically also auto gun is the
only one that goes to the lengths of
doing multi-layer stack ensembling and
all that stuff too so
um let's go on to the next slide
additionally this is the scaled
performance so negative one is the
performance of a random Forest zero is
the the performance of the best system
in a given
um
uh in a given data set and this is
averaged across 104 data sets
um it this is a lot to take in so let's
just go to the next slide where it's
zoomed in so here is for example
multi-class classification so autoglon
is to the left there but and again this
is scaled performance right so negative
one means you're at the performance of a
random Forest zero means you are the
best system right
basically autoglan is able to very
consistently get very close to being the
best system or is the best system in
many data sets
additionally what about competition
results well we've gotten a lot stronger
since 2020 and we placed very highly in
quite a few competitions
um including on machine hack uh first
place and multiple competitions as well
as second place in multiple KO
competitions and recently in the past
couple months uh we actually won a we
actually had somebody use autoglan to
win a Kegel competition we didn't have
somebody an external user actually just
used it in Kegel and won a competition
which is super awesome
um
uh and here's kind of an idea of what
we're talking about when we talk about
the utility of automl right so
this is an example competition Odo which
had 3500 teams uh compete do note that
this is a historical competition so it's
like we are using tools necessarily they
didn't have at the time but this kind of
an idea just stays true regardless
um and basically in four hours autoglan
achieved a score that took the best
human teams over two months to beat on
Kegel right
and when you think about an industry use
case you're not going to have a thousand
cable competition teams with kale Grand
Masters and whatever sharing notebooks
with each other and then getting some
crazy insane Solution that's super
strong right you're going to have like I
don't know a team of three data
scientists working on it for like a week
or two and then they need to work on the
next next test and they need to make
sure that whatever it is is simple
enough that when they hand it over to
another team that they're not gonna
constantly ask them questions till the
end of time right so this is like a
really hard Baseline that we're talking
about here right it's it's like almost
an unrealistic one right but even then
again it took the best team over two
months to beat the solution and the
solution placed rank 14 on the file
private leaderboard which was Kegel gold
which is also the pre one of the
prerequisites to become a cable Grand
Master
um yeah
um also in terms of stability and
robustness
um so on that automl Benchmark paper
um by uh Pietro givers
um autoglan had a success rate of 99.86
when it came to
um running successfully on the data sets
so they had 2080 data sets
um and we had three failures among the
2080 data sets all three of them were
memory errors uh the systems they used
had 32 gigabytes of memory likely if it
would have had more memory we would have
also succeeded on those ones
um and so here uh is a chart from their
paper again this is kind of complicated
to talk about so
um but
basically this is like a Pareto Frontier
of inference speed versus results
strength y-axis is result strength
basically the higher up in the y-axis
the better and you can see that we are
in like the top right of every chart
which means basically we're slow in
inference relative to other systems but
we have the best performance right and
so we looked at this
um and you know we were really happy
that we had very strong performance
right and that was Sheltering through
all these things but also we were like I
bet we can do better in this inference
thing right
so we worked on this
so there's a lot going on here
um first of all I would like to bring
you through the Journey of how automal
systems are improving over time
2020 right there that was our original
paper right uh this dot uh this is like
Auto Glen best quality and you can see
as we go through different versions of
autoglan we improve in both axes right
we get faster as well as we get stronger
in in result quality so we go from 0.1
to 0.3.1 all the way to 0.6 right there
right each time better faster
um and then you can see with 0.6 we have
all these other Dots here and this is
just by tweaking one parameter in Auto
Guan in fur limit
so infer limit is a way for you to force
the end inference speed of the model to
be at least this fast basically you can
think of it that way right so you could
say given batch sizes of 10 000
inference rows I want you to be able to
predict at 3 000 rows per second that's
the kind of thing that you can specify
with infer limit and then internally
when autogun is training it will
restrict how it trains in a way that
guarantees the final result will satisfy
that criteria right
and so then by doing this right by
tweaking just one thing you're able to
span the Pareto Frontier of Solutions in
terms of inference speed and accuracy
um and also if you're a fan of XG boost
for example this is what xgboost is in
this composition and this is a strong
hyper parameter setting xq boost
so this is the relative strength that
we're talking about when I when I
discuss these kinds of solutions
um and uh the other thing if we go back
just for a moment you might see that top
right dot 0.7 prototype
um this is coming soon so 0.7 is
released however we had to delay the
specific technique we're doing in here
we just had a paper accepted at
um icml called xtab which is a
pre-trained tabular Transformer model
that gets state-of-the-art results
and this is basically us ensembling
having that model included in our
ensemble which is going to be available
soon uh probably within a month
so again we're working to push a state
of the art further and further
okay
so we also have a cheat sheet right this
is available on our website so basically
if you check
auto.gluon.ai that's our website I also
you'll just find it on GitHub
um this cheat sheet basically gives you
everything you need to know right it
walks you through installation through
calling those three lines of code it
describes to you some of the arguments
that you could do
um and so on also our website has full
API documentation we have like 50 plus
tutorials on all the different stuff
yeah
um
let me just do a quick time check here
to see if we have time for a demo if I
really rush it we might
um so now let's talk about that whole
multimodal thing right I've been talking
about tabular but we can do a whole lot
more than tabular so imagine you know
you want to predict if a Kickstarter
gets funding or not right well you have
a lot of information here right you have
the images potentially that the
kickstarter has you have the full text
description of the kickstarter you have
how you have tabular information like
how much is the kickstarter trying to
um to raise how much time is left right
all this stuff
um right so let's go on the next slide
yeah and so then this is what like this
could look like
um from a tabular point of view right
where you just put the text in into a
panda's data frame right uh images can
also be a column where you can just the
the column can just be either the byte
array of the image or it can be the path
to the image where you can load it then
so let's go on to the next another one
for example predicting if a pet gets
adopted or not so a pet adoption so for
example given the page so if we go to
the next page so like given the image of
the animal and given a bunch of tabular
information about it plus perhaps the
text description of the animal on the
adoption site this will predict you can
then predict How likely it is for this
animal to be adopted the way that this
can be used is that then they can the
the animal shelter can use this
algorithm to determine which animals
Pages need to be improved so that they
get a better chance of being adopted
right
okay and then what about from Amazon's
perspective right well we have
amazon.com this is definitely multimodal
data right going all the way back to the
you know that product duplication thing
right uh how do we determine if this
image of this product is the same as the
product listed here right is one example
but there are a bunch and again you have
text numerical categorical data like
crazy
move on to the next one
yeah and again this is what it would
look like or this is the Pet Finder one
yeah so uh and so what does this look
like again for multimodal it's the same
deal uh from autoglund.multimodal import
multi-modal predictor and it's the exact
same API same exact thing and if you
want to do it with tabular as well
tabular Sports multimodal um basically
this is like the Ensemble variant this
is the single model variant this top one
and then this is The Ensemble variant
here
where you just call hyper parameters
equals multimodal
and then this will yeah do some magic
and I'll talk about that in a moment
let's go on the next slide
so
first let's talk about model Fusion so
deep neural networks have this nice
property where you can actually fuse
their their neurons together basically
when you're doing uh your fine tuning uh
there's like different techniques like
early Fusion light Fusion but basically
you're able to make them kind of learn
synergistically which is kind of a form
of ensembling but specific to deep
learning
um yeah let's go on to the next uh and
so how good is this out of the box well
these lines of code got second place out
of 2 380 teams on a 100 000 competition
on Kegel out of the box
it's pretty good let's go to next
so this one gets top 20 or or 20th Place
or top one percent this is again that
Pet Finder problem that we just talked
about
um
and now but that's not ensembling right
that's just one uh neural network that
basically we did Fusion on for the
different modalities what if we did this
whole stack ensembling thing right with
this so how do we combine them so
um one is traditional like feature
extractions for example you could
generate embeddings and then feed them
into the model so that's kind of what I
think most people typically do
you could also do a weighted Ensemble
which is another simplest way to do it
and then of course you can do our fancy
multi-layer stack Ensemble stuff and the
idea there is that uh because the inputs
it doesn't matter like what the inputs
are that you train the models are so
long as they're working on the same
problem with a Target prediction uh you
can have like a you know a multimodal
neural network as a base model within a
bunch of tabular models and then stack
it with tabular models so it's
completely compatible and it works
um and basically we find that the stack
Ensemble upperforms the weighted
Ensemble and both of them outperform uh
embedding significantly so if you ever
are working on a problem with
multi-modal and you're like oh let's use
embeddings maybe first think hey maybe
we should Ensemble it instead uh as it
actually gets very strong results or try
out Auto one
okay
um so and now what if we again Ensemble
them together and do our stacking thing
well we get rank one
uh in competitions just out of the box
um on like competitions with over a
thousand teams uh let's do one more and
rank one again in a different
competition
so this is very now we're into very very
strong territory
so Foundation models are getting bigger
as you know I think you might have heard
of something called gpt4 maybe recently
uh yeah and so how do we like deal with
these bigger and bigger models well so
we have some some techniques like
parameter efficient fine tuning and
model distillation built into Auto Glon
so you can bring basically any model to
the table in Auto blonde we can handle
it for the most part to an extent but
basically with parameter efficient fine
tuning we can handle very large models
in like the 30 billion plus range I
think on just a single GPU might be
wrong on the exact number there but we
can handle really big stuff
um
and uh yeah and also with this parameter
efficient fine tuning we are number one
on the raft leaderboard which is a
popular
um leaderboard for basically few shot
learning tasks
um so basically if you only have small
amounts of data we are currently the
state of the art solution for few shot
learning uh in in deep learning uh and
you you can check out all that stuff
um I believe we have a paper on that
coming
um but uh yeah feel free to check it out
I think we also have a tutorial on our
website specifically on this so you can
check it out we are still ranked run as
of this date as well
um okay next slide
okay so the next section is auto
glunt.eda I'm just gonna do a quick time
check so I managed to get through things
pretty quick so actually what I'd like
to do
um
okay let's do Eda and then we can do
um Hands-On demo and then we can do q a
how does that sound Alex
sounds good all right hand it over to
Alex maybe uh five minutes of questions
if uh before we continue yeah let's do
five minutes of questions
are curious to know that you said the
backing so what is the difference
between banking accuracy in that case
say that again packing and accuracy
um so so begging so accuracy is an
evaluation metric
um begging is not an evaluation metric
begging is a way to combine models
together to enhance accuracy
yeah and
right so primarily we're talking about
IID things however generalized strong
IID Solutions generally work well in
imbalanced scenarios too
um so we don't do explicit imbalance
handling outside of doing stratified
splitting of the data so stratified
splitting ensures that imbalance is
proportionally aligned with every split
of the data basically however it doesn't
necessarily fix inherent imbalance in
terms of being able to train better but
some of our models inherently like inner
models inherently do handle imbalance as
part of their logic right like light ubm
for example right
um and this is something that probably
will work on more in future
um but yeah it's just kind of the the
hope is that the Ensemble works well in
both balanced and imbalanced scenarios
at the same time
you know balance the phrase data you you
could do that right or you could use
sample weight so autoguan also supports
sample weights so you can specify the
weight of each sample and that will
inform the training process into how to
value that sample during the training of
the models so we have that support that
will handle imbalance for you and I
think with that you can specify balanced
as the sample weight and that will just
Auto balance it for you across the
classes
yep do you have a question
so one is like I saw that you have many
Ensemble of models like five torch
hugging face but I didn't see tensorflow
in there you still use comes before yeah
so at one point in time we had support
for mxnet tensorflow and Pi torch then
we realized that's a terrible idea
the reason is is because these systems
one are really big to download so it's
really cumbersome to install all three
of them right with GPU support so you're
going to have like this huge container
and the other thing is that they fight
each other a little bit if you try to
install all of them at the same time and
then you import all them at the same
time you'll get random seg Falls and
stuff like that based off of how some of
them try to do optimizations internally
at low level to like speed things up and
it's just not a fun time to deal with it
so generally we've just kind of
converted to only using pytorch as just
a simplification of our design but if
you do have a tensorflow model you like
we have full custom model support and
it's fully generic so you can add your
tensorflow model if you want
like let's say I have a custom High part
module like a not a neural network but
it's some sort of a parameter based
optimization and then I have specific
hyper parameters so how does that is
being handled like uh I download the
model and then called some Auto glue on
wrapper or something like how does that
right so in order to add a custom model
I would recommend just going to the
custom model tutorial and I think it'll
make a lot of sense basically once you
add a model into Auto glance API logic
which is just a thin wrapper around your
model basically then it's fully
compatible with the multi-layer stacking
it's fully compatible with any hpo we do
right and you can fully specify any
hyper parameters it's just a thin
wrapper around and basically you can
pass any information you need to the
model still through the arguments to
bottle go on
is that you said that Ensemble stacking
is better than embedding like work to
back or something so you think using
combining a bunch of Transformer models
would like do a better life is
experimented with some sort of our own
custom GPS that had like a more powerful
results so we have not really gone into
the realm of pre-training a custom like
clip or something like that to do that
but we do use clip for example right so
whatever is like the best open source
model we just pull that off of hugging
face or Tim or whatever right and then
we just fuse all them together and just
fine tune it and get really good results
and yes you can Ensemble things like
swing Transformer and Electra for text
and those there's going to be two
different modalities handling different
kinds of data
yep
okay I'll give one more question yeah
sorry
I like is it worth customizing the model
do you start doing much right
so what I would say is that I don't
claim to speak for the industry domain
expert on their particular problem right
if they think that something is going to
help them then I'm not going to argue
right now I'd rather just give them the
ability to do so if they want in my
experience for the generalized problem
it's going to be hard to be what
autoglan has out of the box unless you
like really really really really really
know what you're doing right is kind of
how I see it so like for example in
machine Learning University which
teaches you know like software
development Engineers machine learning
internally at Amazon they have a
competition right and this com it's like
a Kegel competition basically internally
right Auto go on generally places first
out of like 2 000 students right just
out of the box right no matter what they
do so it's like
you know you know you could try but you
better know kind of what you're doing if
you expect to consistently be able to
improve it right because otherwise if it
was something that consistently improved
it we probably already would have added
it you know yeah
I would add another thing when the model
finished training it's not uh it's not
the final Point once you deploy it in
production there's a cost of support in
this model in production and if data
scientists who worked on the model and
put effort moved on to different job or
a different project who is going to be
supporting it so this question is where
automl plugs in into industrial like
industry setting where
Engineers can support this models
because there's not much code to
maintain
and also you're getting as the as the
time goes the framework gets an update
so in many cases you have to just
upgrade the version retrain the model
and you might just get boost because we
just used the most recent models
um
all right I think that's going to be the
last question we're going to have for
this section we're going to go through
Eda then we'll see if we have time for
some Hands-On notebook stuff again I'd
recommend doing the PIP install auto
glue on thing in your notebook if you
haven't already just to be ready for
that if we have time for it but Alex
feel free to kick it off thank you Nick
so I'm Alex and in this section we're
going to touch on another aspect of data
science which called explorator Data
analysis and how autoclone tools can
help with this so model training is uh
not as like static process
um
it it is it is a iterative process like
in 1962 John turkey uh described the new
field uh he called Data analysis
um and he tried to apply uh scientific
methods to analyze structured and
unstructured data
many statisticians say that it's not
real Fields there's no new things it's
just the statistics
um but he was pretty persistent so in
1977 he wrote a book called exploratory
analysis
and he held that the machine learning at
that time was taking too much emphasis
on statistics and was placed on a proven
uh statistical hypothesis then actually
looking at the data and
get insights from the data get new ideas
um
so the objectives of Eda is to enable
unexpected discoveries in the data and
suggest hypothesis which causes absurd
phenomena and
there's a number of tools which are
useful for Ada you can see on the right
um like computers brought lots of power
to visualize the data in very nice and
consumable way
but what's more important is the fact
that Eda is characterized by attitude
how do you approach the data and not by
the particular techniques
so if you look at the process how data
scientists work with the data in like on
in a real project
um it's not one and done procedure it's
um it's an iterative thinking Loop where
you
first you start with some tool to
collect additional information some new
signals then you observe what what the
signals are and you you might see that
oh there's an outlier there's a strange
missing values
once you do this you can assess the
assess the results
and
reacts to to those observations so for
instance clean the data remove outliers
and and finally you repeat this again
uh since uh it's a very short talk we do
have a low level component support where
you can design your own analysis and
plug your own visualization but we will
focus on the high level components which
have main focus on the tasks and these
are the common tasks data scientists do
so it's just with one line of code you
can get a data set overview it does
basic statistics which you can get from
pandas but we also add additional things
like missing counts types mismatch
we add feature distance which is using
the experiment Spearman correlation Rank
and uh
one of the things you can do with
features which are too close you can
consider dropping them or merging and
this might improve results in some of
the models
and we also give information about
correlation clusters
second second tool in a tool belt is a
target analysis Target in
classification and regression problems
is what you're trying to predict
and this analysis is look at what
factors affect the Target and
for regression problems regression is
for instance when you have
house price prediction you don't you
don't pick the buckets where to put the
prediction you have a Continuum of
values and you need to predict specific
value house price
so we do visualize the targets and we
also try to fit
common distributions this is helpful if
you want to correct the results and all
the information about fitted
distributions with p-values and also you
can click on those links and read the
documentation on scikit-learn what's
this distribution is and how it's
parameterized
yeah
this specific data set has about 100
variables so if you do correlation
analysis on such a big data set first of
all it's going to be slow
and the second thing is
it's going to be cognitive overload so
what we're trying to do here is to
display only things which
uh impactful and in this specific case
look only on the variables which have
high correlation with the target
and for the highest correlation we also
chart them uh in future interaction uh
how they interact with the target
and this tool is probably the most
exciting one it allows you in one line
feeder classifier
and uh all the tool set which is Nick
described before is available here
because we focusing on iterative
exploration of the data we picked I
think it's light GBM out of the box
which is Big because it's a fast
fast tool and you get pretty good
results but you can add as many models
as you can and what it does it samples
the data you have to think about it do
train test split if it's predictor and
then
provides visualization how did that
predictor
do on the on this data set
it does different outputs for
classification and regression so for
classification it visualizes
classifier performance using the
confusion Matrix this is the
checkerboard like graph on the left
uh well the Tells for instance is zero
zero class predicted 147 times correctly
and 33 times incorrectly for aggression
we don't have buckets so we do plot the
residuals which is the difference
between what we predicted and actual and
then we also plot if you have multiple
models a model leaderboard uh how well
each model performed this is helpful if
you for instance trying to explore Which
models would work good is it should I
use random Force should I use like GBM
or maybe there's a neural net so you can
just throw all these models together and
see that k n for instance is not good
and we're not going to train it later
and then
this analysis after that also computes
feature importance which features did
the most impact into the final
performance of the model so you can pick
and choose what features what you want
to keep in the specific case name for
instance was the most impactful thing
and at the end of the report you get
the summary what is the highest
prediction error
uh what which Ross has the highest
and vitros has the
lowest prediction error but it's still
wrong but very close to decision
boundaries so you if you could if you
can think that
um
there's some decision boundaries between
two classes it was just a notch behind
that border and so this two scenarios
are very helpful in understanding why
did the model classify it which brings
us to the next tool
um
why did the model uh did like classified
it this way this tool in one line allows
you to do this so we can take the model
which was taken trained by previous tool
and visualize the rows with highest
error and you would you have a choice
how to do it there are two kinds of
plots the force plot and there's a
waterfall plot
we use a sharply values to visualize it
next tool is the anomalies detection we
use biod open source library to do this
and it also wrapped into one liner and
what it does it assigns anomalies course
using different algorithms so this
library has access to a very wide range
of anomaly detection algorithms I think
they have something something like 25
they can pick and choose and there's a
way to Ensemble those different
algorithms in a in a one way and you
have full control over that
and if you want to know why what are the
top five anomalies and why the top
anomaly was classified as this you can
add two parameters and it will produce
additional outputs to visualize what
features contributed to the score
as you can see the feature
fare was the most contributing factor
for the top one and you can see this
data point on the right
I want to point that anomalies are not
always obvious so in this specific case
we see
two obvious normals on the right but
there are a few of the anomalies on the
left side of the and they don't look
like something special but you have to
remember this this is multi-dimensional
space so this specific data set has I
think 13 features
and this is just a slice across two
Dimensions so even if it's not anomaly
in this slice it's not necessarily not
normally another one
if we go back to this slide you might
see one strange thing so the trend
scores look pretty much uniform
horizontally
but the test set looks like this so
why do some
data points uh why the why the anomaly
score get getting pushed up
in data science there's a thing called
Cabaret shift and it is when your
unseen data is different from the data
you train the algorithm and it's very
important to detect those kind of
scenarios and so covariative detection
tool allows you to
detect those kind of variables
and visualize it so in this specific
case if you do this analysis it will
tell that passenger ID
is the most impact impacting factor in
why this is happening and if we plots a
passenger ID it's just monotonically
increasing ID
if you drop it this shift goes away
some additional visualization is partial
dependence plots
um
the way how it works it is kind of
executing the what if analysis
for instance you have 20 variables and
you want to see
how
age of the car is going to be impacting
the final price of the car
so what this tool does is it fixes all
the variables except the variable you
explore in and then try and all the
possible values for that variable
so h of car one year two years three
years and what you get is this this
charts
and if the lines horizontal this means
the variable doesn't have any impact on
on the video on the target
and it's not very interesting except
that uh the values in that space I
effectively useless for models what we
can do we can just chop the models for
instance in this case
now let's see um
b-class for instance the chart in the
middle on the right after two there's no
impact so we can just try values only
one and two and ignore three
but what's more interesting is where
ideas for future generation come is when
you see those non-linearities and so
these are additional areas where data
scientists can go and explore so this is
a signal that for instance age and fair
are worth exploring as an additional
tool
and finally there's a variation of this
plot if you want to explore two of the
variables how they interacting together
in affecting the target you can do this
with adding two-way
parameter and what you get is this heat
map on the right which
can serve two purposes first one is just
visually you see that for instance
higher fare and young young younger age
was resulting in a higher survival
chance on Titanic
um but in many cases you you might see
some complex interactions like for
instance if there's a circle
shaped areas then you can design new
features and uh
um kind of merge these two features into
one
um yeah these tools are available uh
zero point it's going to be they're
going to be released in the 0.8 release
which is coming soon
we do have notebooks the notebooks
attached to the workshop
yeah this is it we are open source
project everything is on GitHub and
anyone can send contribution or comments
if it works for you great let us know if
it doesn't work let us know too
Nick you wanted to
um to run some
yeah yeah live demos yeah so um first
thanks so much Alex for um you know
presenting the Eda section and I will
say you know like a lot of these tools
kind of sound more kind of like human in
the loop style right where kind of you
you would look into the data and then
you would kind of Tinker with things and
something we're looking into is how do
we kind of take the analysis of Eda and
then automatically make decisions based
off of it it's like a future thing that
we're working on as well
um
so yeah
um so let's talk about this so I think
we do have time for a short Hands-On
demo so again if you want to do this you
can go to the workshop website the
Audubon website
um I don't think the link to the uh
notebooks is on this slide
okay sure so yeah if you if you do go to
the workshop website basically you'll
find a link it's github.com Auto Glon
and then if you just go to github.com
auto go on uh you and then you just
scroll through the projects you should
find pi data 2023 and then if you click
there you should be able to find
notebook and basically
um yeah you can run through that and
actually let's see what happens if I
exit presentation mode and see if
everything explodes in this fragile
setup or not
uh uh I'm gonna assume that it probably
will but you know we can dream oh hey it
kind of works it works weirdly
um okay so and in the meantime I can
actually just start going through it too
so basically this is the website right
um there this is the pi data right and
so well yeah this website right here
also you know so you can take a look at
this after the talk too if you want to
run the notebooks on your own time but
basically if you just click
um
scroll down here so Hands-On notebooks
and so you can just all notes can be
found in notebooks so click that
and so basically with any of these right
we have a open and Google collab or
stage Banker studio lab I'd recommend
Google collab for if you want to do it
live right now just because it's quicker
to set up and so like we could start
with the tabular quick start right
so here we are in collab right and then
you just uncomment this one line here
right the PIP install thing and again
this is why I told you to run it I
didn't follow my own advice of course
and so now I need to wait for it to
install but you know
um right you can run through this and
basically this will show you hey here's
these three lines of code and how it
trains this you know multi-layer stack
Ensemble super easy yeah functionality
like leaderboard that shows you all the
performance of all the different models
including their validation test scores
prediction times training times
um and yeah you have tons of
customization you can also go to the
auto go on website here's our website
right it's just auto.lon.ai here you are
and this gives you full like example
code as well as installation
instructions so pip install auto glom
but we also have an installation page
where we support Linux Mac Windows pip
conda Source install CPU GPU all of it
all right
and we also work on M1 and M2 Max uh uh
so arm arm arm machines we got those
uh and yeah and then we have a bunch of
tutorials right so tabular we got a
quick start multi-label prediction you
know custom metrics custom models
deployment optimizations we also have
multimodal as we said right with the
tons of different things and one thing
we didn't actually talk about is we have
time series so if you're doing time
series forecasting stuff like that we
also have state of the art
um state-of-the-art Auto
malfunctionality for
um for time series we actually have a
paper it's not it's not uh finished
being reviewed yet but basically it's
currently in review at a conference and
we'll probably be sharing that shortly
where we we demonstrate pretty strong
results and then you know that whole
thing about the end-to-end life cycle
for uh productionization we have
autoblawn.cloud this allows you in three
lines of code instead of training on
your laptop spin up an ec2 instance for
example and train on ec2 or train on
sagemaker right in the cloud using
whatever kind of machine you want and
also what we're adding very soon is
distributed training support so for
example in three lines of code spin up a
cluster of 20 machines that each have
128 CPU cores and just go nuts
basically right
um and we're seeing pretty good scaling
uh properties with there because a lot
of things we do at Auto Glen are
embarrassingly parallel like that
begging logic where we have train eight
models of like the same type right on
different sets of the data
embarrassingly parallel turns out when
you have eight distributed machines
you're eight times faster so
um yeah all that stuff is coming up
um let me see if uh and I want to add on
the cloud it's not a required part of
the auto loan experience you can run it
locally but the process if your machine
does not have GPU what you can do is uh
ask autoclone Cloud module to train and
the model on GPU and then bring it back
to your machine and then you can use it
for inference
fully offline and you can mix and match
any combination you can train locally
and deploy to a message maker yep so
like with auto glue on cloud right it's
three lines of code to that till I
basically train on the cloud and then
one line of code to pull the artifact
into local and then run it locally right
so like you can train local deploy to
Cloud train on cloud download to local
and run on local right and this also
allows you to take an artifact that you
trained and deploy it to Cloud super
easy uh with an auto scaling cluster of
inference machines so if you have like a
big workload with lots of inference you
need to do right you can scale that up
without a go on Club
um
yeah let's see if this is finished
installing again I think collab can be a
little bit slow because it has all this
stuff installed and then we need to like
uninstall it because it's old versions
and then reinstall I think we're good
I think we're good so yeah and again you
can do this yourself too but I'll just
do it for demonstration here
um
so yeah so here we go so we we imported
Auto Glon right so now we're gonna train
on this um adult income classification
data set and we're just going to
sub-sample to 500 rows just to keep
things quick right and so if we take a
look at the data here you know this
traditional pandas data frame stuff
right and notice how there's these
columns that are not numbers now a lot
of ml models will not be happy with you
if you pass in you know this kind of
data right you want to convert
everything to numbers or one hot encode
or whatever don't worry about that with
auto go on auto guns built like a tank
it'll handle anything
uh and that's that's kind of our goal
right that's the whole thing of we
succeed on 99.83 of data sets kind of a
deal right basically this is raw data
right this isn't some cleaned up data
this isn't some human manual this is
like raw data random text missing values
blah blah blah right we just we we try
to make it work basically
um
and so yeah I would specify the label
comment because the class cool save path
you can specify the same path like where
it saves the predictor and oh we're
already training all right so here we go
we're training training all these models
so basically notice you didn't even need
to say it was binary classification we
just Auto detect that by looking at the
label column
um you know we tell you stuff like
what's your python version Auto Glon
version what's your operating system how
many train rows columns we do all this
feature pre-processing so we'll like
reduce the size of your data in terms of
memory consumption by 10x by optimizing
the data types and things like that will
generate features we'll identify Boolean
columns automatically
um and then yeah we just get to training
so this isn't doing the multi-layer
stacking thing just because that takes a
little bit longer for like you know a
demo purpose but like basically if you
just set best quality here you'd run
that if you want to do that in the
notebook yeah we train all these
different models K news neighbors like
ubm xgboos neural network extremes blah
blah blah and then Ensemble it all
together here's your test data
um cool that's your test data all right
now printer.predict uh here you go cool
and then yeah you use your accuracy
balanced accuracy mccf1 right got all
that and if you want to see how good is
each individual model right then we can
just call predictor.leaderboard here you
go
uh this is the individual test scores
and validation scores prediction times
of every single model as well as a bunch
of information you can even get the
hyper parameters every model if you call
extra uh extra info equals true here
um yeah and there's a whole bunch more
again I'm not going to get into it all
but there's like you know you can
calculate future importance by
permutation shuffling you can call fit
extra if you want to fit extra models
and then Ensemble on top of it you can
get really fancy with it
um but yeah that's kind of that's kind
of what we got
um we're probably not going to run
multi-model because it would require
gpus uh by the way many models support
gpus and so if
if you do have Appliance then it will
work with it yep yeah so we won't run
the uh the multi-modal tutorial live
here but if you want to run it again you
just need to select the GPU collab
notebook and then it should run right
um but yeah so feel free to run that on
your own time but with that said let's
put the remaining time to questions
um
your Matrix
Matrix is there a do you plan on
introducing any features about like and
features of
like dementia reduction if
dimensionality reduction
um so in what respect would you would
like the goal be there
[Music]
oh yeah yeah so um we actually so if you
call feature pruning dimensional eye
reduction we do have that so we actually
have Auto feature pruning it's not
enabled by default but we will have it
enabled by default soon
um basically we saw improvement from it
it was an intern project so we hadn't
had time to like fully fully uh ensure
everything but basically you just call
um I think it's feature selection or
feature pruning in your fit call it's an
argument and just enable it and
basically what this will do is it will
automatically iterate through training
models and then and then using feature
importance to detect the least important
features pruning them and then just keep
repeating that process until we don't
see performance Improvement and so this
is a way that you can do dimensionality
reduction very effectively it's actually
borrowing off of a technique I used for
that competition uh the Scott Grand
Challenge 2018 because in the catalog we
actually have thousands of features and
so and like 99 of like 90 of them are
like useless so like this iterative
feature pruning thing is super useful
yeah so that's that's available
go ahead
very much for your presentation
where it's just a beautiful thing thank
you so much
um
that'd be saying I I would be a bit
worried and it's it's related to her
question not worry but I wonder if for
example let's say
the most what I think would be the most
common case I traded my GPU on the cloud
and then I want to service my model or
maybe on site or also the account I'll
say CPU with more limited resources
because it's going to be right
I
and so
is there a way in out of the world where
I can
um
when I started training I went to I kind
of say okay I'm gonna run this but I
will service this model in this type of
machine with this memory it has to be
and I expect a prediction in 100
milliseconds is that let's all be
worried no like are you trying to defuse
machine and then you want to right right
so what I would say is we do have the
logic to specify I need to be able to
make a prediction in 100 milliseconds or
something like that that's called the
infer limit argument however the ability
to say not do not use the speed at which
and like the the memory of the machine
that is training but use this
hypothetical machines as a limitation we
don't have yet but we do plan to add
that
um so that that is something we do and
tend to add by 1.0 so by the way Auto
glue on is currently at 0.7 we're
planning to release 0.8 in early June
and then uh we're planning to release
1.0 by like end of November and so one
point I was going to have a whole bunch
of stuff in it and probably a lot of
quality of life things for like industry
use cases like that right and it's
really not that hard to actually
Implement basically the way that we do
things in Auto Glen when we're training
models right we keep track of the memory
usage right and basically we we cut off
models if they take up too much memory
and we just have the memory be the
memory of the machine but if we just
augment things to just pass along this
value that the user specified right then
we could get that working but that's
another comment so we do have containers
built with autoglion for CPU and GPU
variants for training and inference and
you can you can actually limit how much
resources available to other glow on
through using containers right and
additionally like you can yeah you can
train on GPU and then infer on CPU as
well yes yeah
introductions
um to find out the Precision recall or
AUC score of each individual model how
do you do that
yeah so that's the leaderboard
um so Alex Could you actually go back to
the collab notebook uh it should be the
first tab first Tab and then just scroll
down to the leaderboard call
uh yeah right there right so basically
each model is its own predictor right
it's its own valid thing yeah and so you
can just pass the data through it get
the predictions right and then score it
uh
oh oh uh you can call uh so it's not
here by default in this one uh it's
there this is dot evaluate predictions
however you can get those there so
basically if you do leaderboard call you
can call Dot leaderboard extra metrics
equals and then you just specify your
list of metrics that you want as
additional output columns there and then
it will score it on every every model
to a custom
layer let's say you want to build a
fully connected layer or something you
can do without anyone library or you'll
be called python Global you can do it
you can do it in Auto glue on
um so I mean if you're talking about
stacking wire
or
is
to like
arch.nn.linear and then you can do that
it's just that well so we we aren't we
aren't a framework that like is allowing
you to like build a custom neural
network from scratch using Auto gluons
API this would be a custom model right
or it'd be a hyper parameter to a model
where you're adjusting how it works
based off of the hyper parameters so for
example if you wanted to do that this
would be like you would create your own
custom model and then you would add it
via Auto glance thin wrapper logic as a
compatible model to Auto Guan and then
you'd train it alongside although it
matters it would Ensemble with all of
them right yeah you do have tutorial on
websites in advanced section for Tableau
where it goes through how to add a
custom model uh you've you have to
implement preprocess and I think feeds
and that that's that would be it yeah
and you can check our source code right
since we're open source you can check
how we implemented all of our individual
models right it's generally it's not
super complicated some of the ones we
use very commonly are a bit more
complicated because we've optimized them
but beyond that it's a it's a pretty
thin wrapper around things that you just
have you have a model that works and you
just kind of plop it in and it should be
compatible yeah
oh
was it custom written
um
so which example are we talking about
in what
this
this pre-processing oh on the dogs
oh sorry custom oh and the custom models
um so let's let's go to
um just it's scroll down just a tiny bit
it's implementing so it's in the
underscore pre-process yes this would be
something that you would write yourself
right but this is just the custom model
implementation right pre-processing
could be nothing it could just be return
the the stuff right it's just if your
model needs custom pre-processing of the
data right in order to do what it needs
to do so for example filling missing
values or converting to one hot encoding
or anything like that right then you
have the ability to do it by just this
underscore pre-process you just plop all
that logic into there
right this is model specifically
processing there's a pipeline to
preprocess uh incoming data which is
like Global for the whole
um for the whole run but uh each model
is uh requires a little bit different
inputs for instance linear models would
need you to one hot and code categorical
variables uh while decision trees do not
need that and so this kind of
differences would be encoded in in this
area yeah and again most users probably
won't need to make custom models right
the whole point is you just use Autumn
out of the box it should work well this
is more if you have a special scenario
or you just kind of want to see if you
can push things further right or if you
want to contribute a model to autoglo on
that you think is awesome and then you
want to open a PR of your custom model
implementation
is there any way that I can remove a
model from
yep so basically it's all in this uh
predictor.fit hyper parameters argument
so this hyper parameters is actually
just a dictionary of a bunch of models
right and including all their hyper
parameters and you can get what the
default dictionary is I forget the exact
thing um you can you can check our docs
on it but basically you can get the the
default dictionary and then from there
you can just edit it however you want or
you can call predictor.fit and then call
an exclude models argument and then just
pass the list of models names that you
want to not be trained
so there's a parameter called excluded
excluded model types which you can pass
into feed function and then in this
specific case it excludes k n neural
network by
torch and I think one version of flight
GBM
any other questions
yep it's all available online so if you
go to the website or I think the GitHub
basically we have a link to download the
slides right uh yep so our slide deck is
fully available yeah it's this link in
on the website like this yes
and I think this is getting recorded too
I heard so maybe yeah maybe you'll also
be able to view the video at some point
yeah
so is that the last part is the humor or
you mentioned as a library or something
literally and we want to throw a kitchen
sink at it no no it's humor but you know
it's it's a it's a it's a it's a phrase
right it's kind of like throwing the
kitchen sink at something means using
everything you have at your disposal and
like we're just gonna Chuck it all right
that's what we mean yeah
yeah the philosophy we approach approach
building autoclone is we take the best
available tools open source gives and uh
other Glen is an aggregation point for
many open source projects uh in in this
remark so that's why we we just support
most of the major machine learning
Frameworks and if there's something
better we will add it yep and exactly
and so a big part of it is that we have
ways to detect if something is better
right so we do large-scale benchmarking
regularly right and in that in that
process we like can we basically take
the prediction probabilities of all the
different models and then we can run
simulations of like what works best on
average right and with this we're able
to get like really strong configurations
and so if anyone has a new model then we
can just if they make it compatible
without a go on then we can run our
benchmarks with that model simulate if
that model is going to be useful or not
right and then that automates our
decision if we add it right and so we
can basically flexibly as the field
progresses as the available models
change we can basically very quickly
adapt to whatever is the magic formula
that kind of works best right over time
yes yes so you can add text image and
tabular data all at the same time
and that that's that's that's the power
of the fusion logic is one which is the
Multi Auto Glass Dot multimodal and then
the ensembling logic which is
autoglawn.tabular and you can combine
both together by calling Auto
glen.tabular and specifying hyper
parameters equals multimodal
um and this is basically what has gotten
like first place in multiple
competitions right just out of the box
just because who the hell is going to
build a multimodal fused neural network
fine-tuned with all these tricks on top
of a multi-layer stack Ensemble for a
competition I would say machine hack
competitions where we got the first
second place uh it was multimodal
competition so I think it was Text Plus
tabular yeah but also like you know
internally we verified that like this
works very well again for like you know
the amazon.com product pages right those
are inherently multimodal and so
autoglone is used very widely within
Amazon for determining a bunch of uh
properties of of uh products right
basically we have like 20 000 binary
classification problems on determining
if a product has or has not something
right doesn't have an electrical outlet
uh or you know does it contain kangaroo
meat or something like that right just
whatever random thing they need to
legally very verify or you know disclaim
about the product right and so there's
like 20 000 of these problems are they
gonna have a specialized solution for
every single one not it's not realistic
right so we use Auto Glon for that right
and then we just work to ensure that
auto Glide is generally performant
across a large scale of data a lot like
across the board basically right
yeah we will take one last question and
this gentleman
IA
sorry can you say this again
oh monotonic constraints yes
we do okay you know this is very
interesting you bring this up because
we're actually working on this not
specifically for a particular problem
but actually as a way to enhance the
power of multi-layer Stack ensembling
because we want to force monotonic
constraints on the prediction
probabilities of Prior layers of models
so that we can't we don't have models
saying oh Model A predicted high
therefore I'm going to predict low right
because that's that's like a noisy thing
and it causes weird things to happen
very very weird things to happen by the
way you need to really understand what's
going on but it's it's bad so we want to
enforce monotonic constraints on those
things but also I think in that process
we probably want to also think about
monotonic constraints as a general
uh tool for the user to be able to
specify I think that would be super
awesome the tricky part is I don't know
how to enforce that generically across
all model types trees you can do it I
don't know about neural networks but
it's something we're going to be looking
into
thank you everyone I hope this was uh
useful and we're looking forward to hear
from you yeah thanks so much
[Applause]